let's talk about maple worth murders you
having fun doing that joe
oh man conan i'm having a ball man and
and and if you didn't notice about me i
don't know if you have this this
this this thing in you but i love
mysteries
i love murder mysteries man yeah hey
i love this show man i get a chance to
uh
uh reconnect with my friends from snl
and paul carell and john
lutz and and tina fey did a guest guest
appearance on the show
maya did a guest appearance on the show
friend fred and
oh man this is uh it's amazing eddie
sandberg everybody jb the people that
are getting to do this show
are the best of the best i'm sure my
call is coming
i'm sure hey you leave your hair like
that
and i'm telling you with your hair like
that i
know you killed somebody you know
you are a killer yeah there's no mystery
there's no mystery if i come on like
this
there's no mystery there's no mystery
right you did it you
killed somebody
[Laughter]
but i'm gonna tell you conan i've always
been a big fan of shows
like that noise of love i i just love
murder she wrote but i just love me some
damn colombo
love colombo come on man come on now you
now you do you think if colombo came
back
that i would be a perfect colombo yeah
i could see that man come on come on man
come over had that little delivery he
come he come over to see you
he's like yeah yeah okay uh i see
i get it i get i get
he figured it all out he forgot he said
one more thing
he said one more thing he got your ass
he
got you he got your ass conan he got it
you did
he got jb that's why you'd be so perfect
for colombo
because you're very friendly like he was
and you're very personable but then i
could see you leaving but then never
wanting to leave
because you don't stop talking so you
start to leave and then you go
one more thing and then you have another
you know how that looks cool bro lumbo
come on i still you know you know my man
of fashion i love a good trench coat
i love a good trench coat put a little
twist coat on come on
come on yeah i don't know
you are the best you pitch you are such
a good
idea pitcher i don't know how you didn't
get every single idea you had on
snl because i want to now i want to
watch bro lumbo i want to watch you
as bro lumbo let me get the word out on
this you can watch all episodes
all episodes of maple worth murders
great show
exclusively on quibby right now and then
you can get your
fix of jb smooth because i'll tell you
something jb
during these times nothing makes me
happier than talking to you
you love you man you bring i love you
too you bring joy
happiness more crazy ideas than i've
ever heard
in a 15-minute period you're uh you're
you're
a special special man you really are hey
man and these times like you said man we
need laughter man we need
we need each other uh we definitely have
a lot in common man and uh
and i thank you for your inspiration and
you gave me a lot of work man when i
worked with snl
call me i would bring my ass downstairs
in that elevator
how could we not yes for you and we
would have a ball mail
anytime anytime you would come on the
late night show
i'd be laughing at rehearsal before you
even said anything
you would make me laugh so hard before
you even said anything you said
man yeah the blessed man to uh reconnect
with all out
yeah beautiful friends and family man we
just want to stay safe out here
and stay safe at some point at some
point we're gonna see each other
yeah and if i be in a pocket i'm gonna
have some moose
and i'm gonna spray the front of that
hair i'm gonna put it back up the way it
belongs put it back up it collapsed
it wasn't what i'm gonna do that's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna know it's good
too
egg whites put egg whites in your food
in your hair and then cook it just a
little bit
just a little bit it's a little bit oven
at 350 for like five minutes
five minutes tops and then your hair
will be back to
whoo